bonsoir jacques souquet à merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france un
confinement brasse tic
on vient de le voir est ce qu on avait
le choix
selon vous oui bonsoir en fait à mon
avis on n'a pas le choix on n'a pas le
choix et en fait je crois qu'il devrait
y avoir auparavant des actions
préventives en fait l'ailé des jours de
fête ont été un tout petit peu permissif
il ya eu plein de rencontres le jour de
la saint sylvestre et puis appeler on se
paye maintenant les pots cassés donc
avec cette augmentation drastique des
cas des milliers par jour
du jamais vu depuis la première vague en
fait et depuis même le blast 2 be good
donc le 4 août se passer donc là on est
dans une situation très critique en fête
avec tout à fait comme vous ne venez de
bien de le dire dans votre reportage les
les hôpitaux qui sont saturés les les
lits de soins intensifs qui sont en
partie limitantes qui sont saturés et
donc bon je crois que on n'avait pas le
choix on doit actuellement faire ce
confinement ce lockout totalement
effective mon reportage on entendait un
des personnes qui faisaient la queue un
devant les hôpitaux à beyrouth au liban
pour espérer obtenir un lit est ce que à
l'instar du grand test au début de la
pandémie est ce que il ya ce sinistre
tri des patients au liban vous en est
arrivé là
également vous avez été contraints de
faire cela oui oui tout à fait en fait
et ça c'est une question éthique
assez assez difficile en fait on a connu
des genres de tri pendant la guerre du
liban qui a qui a traîné une dizaine
quinzaine d'années
là on s'est dit bon de toit allait bien
jusqu'à ce qu'on ait eue il ya quelques
mois bien quelques jours déjà là cette
augmentation en crescendo des cas et
donc on se de nouveau on se rencontre
avec les partis étiquettes les partis
qui pensent spécifiquement à cette
question comment trier qu'est-ce qu'il
faut d'ailleurs quelles sont nos
ressources donc à chaque centre
hospitalier à chaque région ça le souci
c'est le sou c'est donc le tri devrait
être proportionnelle à ce qu'on a et ça
ça nous pose un problème social éthique
parfois religieux assez important donc
surtout si on prend des ddd des idées de
comme l'âge est ce que c'est éthique de
trier parages de trier par différence et
c'est là donc c'est pas facile du tout
là on est on est on est face à ceux ci
on va faire avec je crois que la
meilleure chose c'est d'augmenter nos
capacités comme vous voulez bien de dire
mais je crois que enfin je crains que
qu'on arrive à un maximum est donc là de
nouveau on sera amené à faire un tri un
peu plus serré probablement d'autant que
le premier ministre démissionnaire à
samedi à mener n'est pas vraiment
rassurant et il dit l'épidémie est hors
de contrôle et le système de santé
risque l'effondrement est ce que c'est
le cas selon vous qui travaillaient à
l'hôpital
oui mais en fait comme je viens de dire
il n'y a pas eu de d'action préventive
on voyait venir que si pendant les fêtes
les gens vont se rassembler vont se
rencontrer
vous me direz ensemble vont faire la
fête à la saint sylvestre c'était un
tout petit peu pelé vient prévu tout ça
mais bon les autorités n'ont pas trop vu
tout ceci
et moi c'est moi
elles n'ont pas vu où elles n'ont pas
voulu voir je n'entre pas dans ceux des
dans ce débat mais même même la
population en fait même si ici quelqu'un
vous dit que peut très bien vous pouvez
faire la fête bon il fallait un tout
petit peu les zones et les choses et
donc se confiner sans qu on soit obligé
ou pas obligé donc bon mais tout de même
on est là aujourd'hui et je crois que
comme vous dites que vous avez bien dit
au début
là on n'a pas le choix on n'a pas le
choix on n'a plus le choix
bien que de l'autre côté on a une crise
économique et sociale très importante
donc je ne sais pas si c'est aussi
important tous pas que le corona mais
pour un cola koffi 19 mais tout de même
sur le premier plat actuellement c'est
la copie 19 bon donc je crois qu'on peut
mettre les choses les autres choses à
côté essayé de faire avec l'aco vide se
confinait essayé de traiter le mieux les
patients et on va voir dans les dix
prochains jours
ma dernière question rapidement s'il
vous plaît quid du vaccin au liban oui
bon comme on était bien entendu le meut
le ministre
il y a quelques mois s'est dit que bon
ils ont déjà fait la commande des
vaccins pfizer le modern en est
probablement spoutnik le russe et donc
on les a pas encore bon ceci dit quand
tout a dit ben ça rentre dans un jeu
politique au social au et caetera et
donc qui est ce qui va amener quelques
sûr hélas le plan national sur quelles
priorités
bon je crois qu'on va attendre ceux ci
dans les prochains jours j'espère très
prochainement pour recevoir ce vaccin
est commencé et qu'on vient de dire
docteur casalino ce n'est pas aux les
amener à l'hémisphère nord seulement à
se vacciner donc ce virus qu'en 6e
circulent librement il fait cesser ces
mutations et donc il peut muter
n'importe où au monde
le passé et le faire des pandémies de
nouvelles pandémies et c'est ce qu'on
craint c'est ce qu'on veut pas merci
jacques joker d'avoir été avec nous dans
vu de l'extérieur pour nous avoir parlé
de cette situation inquiétante au liban
également